la main
sur le terre-plein central la
censure à l'encontre de m
streit ne doit pas être un
frein
on n'attend que justice
encadrés par des forces de
un collectif des milliards de
dollars de prêts à assister à
son procès qui oppose depuis
rené galinier incarcéré pour
parler sur la réforme de la
régulation financière un an
après -0 4% et le centre de
production c'est une nécessité
pour notre papy galinier si
aujourd'hui
il ya un petit peu
l'âge de 6 ou 7 dans le monde
si les présents dans les
milieux qu'on appelle
extrême-droite
c'est peut-être parce qu'il a
tué sur le coup reste des fonds
de cette année
la libération de ce
septuagénaire devenu symbole de
l'auto défense nationale et des
affaires islamiques par
l'extrême droite
pour le collectif de gauche
rassemblée hier soir il
faut-être pacifiste
et quand arrêter le sectarisme
ce discours-là
absolument inacceptable
e il a pas lieu de se tenir sur
la place publique et
certainement pas sur la place
jean-jaurès aujourd'hui se
mêler de politique qu'on
pourrait appeler selon forbes
une politique discriminatoire
pathé le fait que les trois
chimistes de l'extrême droite
alors
c'était ce contexte-là qui
fait qu'on est là aussi on
sépare que l'extrême droite
c'est ce discours et cette
politique que l'on vient ici
combattre vox populi a prévu
une action par mois pour se
faire entendre il faudra compter
et sur l'extrême gauche pour
donner de la voix également